so we've been here for like over an hour
and a half now we haven't asked you how
your time in Japan's been yet oh yeah
you've been living your best yeah dude
so I love it dude it's just it seems
insane that like people just live here
and like
what do you mean by that what do you
mean by that it's wild dude like people
just [__] straight up go to work and
like and and live here when you think
about it I'm like everything is awesome
that is the most weeps thing you've said
you want the biggest
we
know which is like thing thing in Japan
it's like oh no but like it is like that
you don't understand it no literally it
is like that
it's I don't know what it is like I I
mean it's just a magic to it I think
it's not supposed to work like Japan is
not supposed to work but it works
somehow I don't know just
everything is
um everything that I would normally look
to with like my political understandings
and like everything I know about the
world like Japan basically took on and
was like no no we'll make it work and it
does somehow like you have 3 800
homeless people in the entire [__]
Island but like at the same time it's
not like the country's doing really well
economically right you know what I mean
younger Generations are very frustrated
with a lack of opportunity people are
just not dying so much so that you got
[__] Japanese Yale economists talking
about how like oh I have a solution kill
yourself to the older people you know
what I mean you have all this [__]
that's like so
it you have uh what I would consider to
be like oh my goodness that's just my
phone you have what I would consider to
be like a ticking Time Bomb you know
what I mean like capitalism is like
hyper capitalist but it's it's held
together by like thousands of years of
like rigid structure and tradition in
like unflinching in the face of like uh
you know a a world that uh is is
constantly being like no no things
should be very different like things
should be more free so in some ways it's
shitty like with the you know the hentai
stuff
social issues sensitive yeah like
blurring of the penises of vaginas like
that's weird
but but also at the same time I think
like that is still the reason why you
know you have such an emphasis on like
cleaning your own space making sure that
you have uh making sure that you leave
the place better than you you uh uh then
you first yeah it's a very like uh I
would say like a collectivist but like
that collectivist Society creates like
very uh uh like uh selfless people oh
yeah yeah you know where it's like it's
I'm I'm at the bottom of the priority
and everybody else is above me kind of
thing right so it's like that and when
everybody is like that then everyone's
looking out for each other yeah yeah
which is crazy because at the same time
it's like insanely capitalist so you're
like how the [__] does this work because
in America we're insanely capitalist is
a hyper capitalist dystopia but then
also people are hyper individualists so
when you have that that's when you get
to like no Health Care everybody has a
gun you know full Freedom yeah you have
the freedom to like die from uh you know
not getting your your diseases treated
right right but um but you don't have
that in Japan you have the economic
structure which I think is like wild uh
and and you know inherently incredibly
exploitative but then it still somehow
works and I still haven't figured out
exactly what the [__] going on like I
don't know how it works I don't even
think Japan's figured that [__] out
there just like it it doesn't make any
sense because like I mean I guess that's
why they call it a post-war economic
Miracle right yeah yeah well I think a
lot of people just take a lot of uh a
lot of Pride and a lot of care and what
they do in a way that is kind of hard to
expect of people in Western countries
because we'd be like [__] that I'm not
working and yeah McDonald's for five
[__] dollars an hour yeah yes I think
in Japan there's not really that concept
of you know [__] your employer for not
paying you enough there's like no such
you take what you're given right yeah I
mean yeah but also like how do they
survive you know what I mean like that's
the other that's what I'd understand we
you guys have talked about uh you know
like anime uh not voice actors obviously
but like the the people that addresses
yeah the animators like how the [__] do
they survive by doing multiple jobs
multiple jobs or you know as you might
have noticed overworking is overworking
or stuff is really cheap in Japan that's
true it is very true you want to live
off literally the bear Essentials you
can kind of do it pretty cheap in Japan
yeah you won't live well but you can
survive you know that that that does
blow my mind like because housing you
know what I mean like that's a huge
problem yeah yeah there's a big problem
in Tokyo yeah yeah uh and not even just
in Tokyo but like I just I I don't
understand how um you they spend so much
less money overall and yet like this is
a this is an issue that they've been
able to
not fully eradicate obviously no I mean
the economy certainly still do a lot
better than America in some aspects yeah
I think so yeah
um the the best example is like is the
the railway system right yeah it's a
Marvel obviously it's like uh originally
it's government funded because you have
to do it like that that's a massive
infrastructure project you have to get
the government and the tax dollars to
pay for it right yeah
but also now it's like fully privatized
yeah so that's the reason why you see
like uh so many Railway uh switches in
between and like all this like
frustrating uh all these like
frustrating things that you experienced
without even realizing why it's
happening well that's because it's owned
by like multiple different uh multiple
different companies right
um but it still [__] works yeah yeah
it still works it's not supposed to in
America those trains will be [__]
eating each other every day they would
literally be like hitting each other
non-stop the most inconvenience you get
in Japan in terms of it being different
companies competing is that I guess you
have to change Gates yeah yeah so you
won't be on the Metro you have to clock
you have to go yeah yeah that's what I
that's what I mean literally the like
bare minimum and that's crazy when you
have like uh such a you know intricate
system and and yet the trains [__]
run on time yeah that's what I mean it's
not supposed to be that way like it
doesn't make sense you go to the UK
uh a lot of places where Railway is
nationalized have privatized shouts at
the Margaret Thatcher that [__] [__]
um
no no no no no of course not no exactly
so like that privatization has genuinely
destroyed like what is otherwise
something that people hold on to as a
Lifeline because like if you're poor
that's the one thing you have you know
what I mean like that's how you travel
um we don't even have that in America so
like that's a foreign concept public
transit is like not even a thing yeah
um and and you see that like
privatization is supposed to destroy uh
uh the the uh things that otherwise
government should be able to handle but
in Japan it just [__] works and it
works really well and it like blows my
mind when I watch it when I see it well
I I think that's just a general kind of
like culture in Japan where what no
matter what your job is you should take
pride in your work to make it the best
it can possibly be and that translates
to every single aspect of Japanese
culture whether you be [__] by buying
fruits from the supermarket or going to
a restaurant or getting any kind of
craftsmanship yeah it doesn't always
work there are a lot of things that
Japan is definitely not caught on to
um just like adopting to the online uh
world is tough or the receipt system
yeah yeah why like yo you're using paper
like yeah yeah like when I did my taxes
I have to I have to scan every receipt
and upload them that is insane dog that
makes no sense like it makes no sense
right they're just playing on hard mode
like what the [__] and like you know
even though you mentioned the trains
like there are certain trains if you
want to book them where it becomes like
a you know a doom like a dark souls one
hit level of difficulty it's like it's
for no reason like just some things that
just didn't quite adapt the way they
should have and it ends up making this
kind of really [__] up Amalgamated
system of like booking and stuff that
doesn't quite work right but it works if
you know how to do it because people are
pretty persistent here if they want
something I mean even just doing like
general paperwork in this country is the
most like asinine thing ever right
because everything is layered behind 10
layers of paperwork but you could you
could uh oh I know I had to [__]
write like all the forms to like get
into the country yeah yeah it's not
gonna have the opposite of then he was
super easy
yeah
no this was not easy at all
also a government building you could
just walk in you can just see where all
the Walkers are the Stacks and stacks of
papers yeah because they're all working
analog this can't be efficient no it's
not and it's not it's so hard for
bookkeeping you can't search like you
you could just search on if you
modernize it yeah it makes no sense yeah
they're so that's that's that sort of
stuff also is like very strange to me
that they're they're like nope we're
gonna keep using paper well again it's
that whole idea of like holding on to
tradition yeah
elderly people yeah but the systems
there is a positive to that because like
it probably and I don't even know this
uh is the case or not but I suspect that
it probably keeps certain economies
alive oh for sure the more the more you
like stick to paper for example the more
you like literally have the have you
guys ever seen the office yeah yeah the
American version like thunder Mifflin
going out of business because no one
uses paper anymore yeah but you have
like what is it is it Muji like there's
like companies that just like make paper
paper products yeah but then they also
like become conglomerates and also sell
like vibrators and [__] too on the side
which is wild that's like a very that is
a very like uh you know uh East Asian
country thing to have like I think at
least for the government as well I think
a lot of the priority is just keeping
jobs yeah and fortunately to if you want
to modernize things it normally means
you either gonna move people around or
figure out something new yeah and that's
that's tough uh also Japan is just like
in general really bad at adopting new
things oh yeah terrible yeah
occasionally they'll take something like
a toilet and they'll be like we're up in
the game yeah and other stuff they'll be
like ooh they're like but we're keeping
the fax machine just in case you know
yeah I mean we've just started I've just
started seeing contactless like payment
machines yeah just starting wait that's
new that is new well for for credit
cards right for credit cards for a while
for Seeker like the uh yeah for debit
cards and all that kind of stuff that's
just a little more new like that's been
for me I took that for granted I'm like
oh yeah it's great okay you've been to
the UK right yes no one uses cash yeah
that's that's the oh my God I have to
[__] have like a coin wallet like I
have a coin wallet too yeah that's
insane like there's this oh no I don't
want any of that man you can keep it
yeah and it makes keeping bookkeeping
like you mentioned hard because I have
to then keep all the receipts yeah and I
have no trail of it existing if it's if
I lose that exactly that that kind of
stuff is crazy like that that that
definitely blows my mind
um but overall it's there not to weeb
out too much but you can weave out it is
it is very it is beautiful like there's
problems and as every country does but
there but there's so much good here yeah
so much amazing it's so beautiful like
that's what I mean when I they're like
[__] are just going to work and
I'm just sitting there like looking
around
that's crazy
he's so sick you know what I mean yeah
yeah which probably is like a byproduct
of me being here for the first time and
like anime definitely breaking my brain
I mean it definitely like for I think
the big one that we've always mentioned
about a bunch of the podcast is like
vending machines wear off yeah they will
real quick yeah
like a coffee machine uh the vending
machine coffee I I remember moving after
moving to Japan I thought I would get
those kinds of coffees every day uh when
I was a tourist I would like go to the
vending machine in the morning get a
coffee and I'd be like this is it this
is the life moved here didn't drink it
at all no no I I I I understand like
that that's not I'm not that fascinated
with the vending machines it's like a
very easy example yeah yeah but oh my
God the [__] the the 7-Elevens dude
holy [__] I will say that is one thing
that never seems to like I never seem to
I always appreciate it yeah egg salad
dude it's like it's just so good and
you'll appreciate it more if you ever
leave Tokyo because you'll be in the
middle of nowhere middle of nowhere in
Japan you're like an hour away from
anywhere restaurant but there'll be a
7-Eleven fully stocked yeah every food
24 7 as well it's like this is just the
BET like if you go to rural uh Wales
it's like good luck yeah
there's no food maybe there's a Greg's
three hours from you but there's no food
yeah yeah and then the shops shut at
four so if you don't have food by four
and you know you're just you're just
[__] like four on certain days it
depends on the story the point is yeah
you can't you don't get food like that
yeah okay it's just convenient in it
yeah it's something that we've
definitely taken for granted UK still
kind of looks like Vinland Saga honestly
I mean yeah Danes did a number on them